the rugged rusty planet like we have
never seen it before
its craters clear enough to count and
its crimson hue in plain view
as the perseverance rover descends these
images from nasa's many cameras on board
track every tense moment of the perilous
landing last thursday
tango delta confirmed perseverance
faithfully on the surface of mars ready
to begin seeking the sands of past life
they called the entry the seven minutes
of terror due to the daunting technical
challenges
the vehicle had to glide through the
ultra-thin atmosphere
and as the landing site in the jezreel
crater fast approaches
the force of the engines conjures the
dust around it
before it finally settles and the unseen
world is a feast for the eyes
and it's just really exciting to see um
you know these scenes look familiar
to us you know they look earth-like in a
sense you know you see them
the mountains back there and the rocks
and things it just
really is the surface of an alien world
as if pictures weren't enough on board
the rover are two microphones
this the first time the world can hear
the sound of mars
for the next two years perseverance will
drill down into the big question
did life here once exist there is signs
of we won't say life anymore because
we've
virtually given up on that but maybe
signs of ancient life once there
and again the drill uh in this crater
which we believe used to have water
maybe uh we might get sort of the first
strong signs of that as well
those in mission control describe the
landing on this ancient planet
as a rush of tension and drama this
historical feat
brings us closer to its secrets ashna
harinag
sky news